[Music]
is there a
career that you guys think you can just
go in
no experience and just start doing [ __ ]
babysitter
babysitter is that a career don't you
need experience to be a babysitter well
he said no experience
i'm a mom like uber eats maybe yeah
that's experience
what about no experience like just you
just blind like grubhub or doordash
you have to know how to drive
you don't have the experience in that
you just walk into doing it yeah like uh
welding or something you have your own
experience of life yeah that would count
as expensive
babysitter is a pretty good answer you
can't use that that would you want to be
able to use it then i guess oh wait what
so like entry-level jobs
entry-level jobs car washers literally i
have no experience and i walk in there
going like
higher yeah is there any job that you
would dare just be like breathe i'm a
car washer i'd be super down to do that
scientific experiment
like a test of the test subject you take
the pills
yeah you get paid for that yeah you
would do that
what if your hair is shin you're
different i'm saying it's a job that
doesn't require
to be skilled and you can walk
a lot of times too you have some kind of
condition that they're researching so
you could maybe benefit from it
rephrasing it okay white collar job okay
no experience
which one would you dare just walk in
give me the job just customer service
stock brokers
services pam's job broker yeah ham's job
being a receptionist yeah our
receptionist okay yeah yeah
data entry i think it's the easiest
um i love tedious work entry-level job
so like i love this [ __ ] you go like
this and then you
you go on your excel sheet and you type
in what you see on the paper that's all
it is
true true true well in india
they just arrested a 23 year old man
well according to
certain documents he has they think he's
23 years old
he could be older but he worked at over
16 different private hospitals at
different medical camps as a doctor
and he's only had education up until
fifth
grade i i believe it just because indian
people are [ __ ] smart
true okay that's not the way you're
looking doctor
so yeah i just wore a lab coat and
started like we did a jk news on this a
while ago yeah really multiple yeah if
you can
uh kind of uh we've done a few already
on the show
yeah really one i see it's another one
yeah so this guy
being pretending to be a doctor is like
a pretty common thing
like really common like we might even
know somebody you know
that's because frank gabby now started
it oh true yeah like we might
it's so common that i wouldn't be that
could happen
against the idea like let's just say
what if like we meet something it's very
common who says that they're a doctor
okay at a barber shop you want to meet
them at a barbershop or not uh maybe you
want like a tire shop or like a fast
food restaurant or like wherever right
anywhere playing true but then you meet
one and then like
you just kind of don't question the fact
that they say right and then they you
know say big words
and they have a white black coat it's
very convincing
even a degree or whatever like there's
not like all those things combined
together
and they even have a degree yeah they
might even have two yeah
right i mean the it's just i'm just
saying like the possible
comments are endless got it true it is a
highly
high probable chance that it can happen
to
any of us that's right if you're a good
bullshitter you could just be anything
in the world
true you're gonna be the president and
if you're around people who are very
true
very true if you're around trustworthy
people who just kind of go like well
yeah this is a hospital
you are wearing a lab coat i believe it
and for new viewers we're not talking
about anybody specific it's just yeah
yeah we're just positing yeah we're just
you know we just know that there's just
the world is a crazy place anything can
happen how many people we've talked
about on this show
right fraud happens everywhere folks
everywhere that's right
yeah so for this guy his name is
veeragandam
teja we'll just call him teja for now
doctor
doctor doctor ted doctor
dr taja so yes uh earlier i said he
worked in 16 private hospitals conducted
several medical camps and he even
volunteered
as a police officer uh for that so noble
oh yeah and how he helped migrant
workers on the pandemic
but yeah he uh he recently got uh
apprehended for i guess impersonating
all these but you can't arrest me i'm
the officer
oh sorry officer by the way do you have
a fever
yeah he would actually have gotten away
with it i would say
if it wasn't for it wasn't for the damn
meddling
wife so his wife outed him oh the wife
always got to shut him down
why he's doing bad things it's the job
of the wife
hey i'm out there trying to try to lie
to the world let me know i'm a doctor
okay why did she shut down her own thing
because she's not sharing she's living
good
she's not he's not sharing she might
have been yeah
if he also lied to her oh
she got married yeah she knew what she
knew she was getting with a liar
maybe he's really good at lying that's
true no way of telling this whole time
he was lying about his dick and then
they got married and on the wedding
night she's like you [ __ ]
i was expecting what the [ __ ] i'm
telling the whole world what else are
you lying about
that could very well be i'd be mad yeah
i would definitely rat someone out for
that too you didn't say
dr officer had a [ __ ] micro penis
[Laughter]
well to be clear this is also his second
wife so he's
already gone through a divorce
beforehand uh and about the first one
dude
maybe he yeah he may be lied about being
oh i've never been married
maybe he lied about the first 12 that we
don't even know about right true
yeah anyways the second wife she filed
uh
a mental and physical harassment against
him so it wasn't even for the lies that
he
he did in terms of getting these fake
jobs and whatnot he was mentally and
physically harassing her and so
she went to the police and basically
complained and got the police show up
and when the police showed up
for some reason he was also compelled to
have the police scratch
out his criminal record for one of his
identities
wow which is i'm like wait what you're
getting you're getting away with having
multiple
identities you've worked as a doctor a
police officer
and now you're telling the police to
scratch and clear out your your criminal
history on
one of your identities he's a master
manipulator huh he's convincing
he actually did it they listened to him
so they tried to do it so they tried to
they tried look at his uh they call it a
person's rowdy sheet
oh that's tight i want i wish it was
called the router i guess that's
like an inventory ma'am yeah that sounds
fine
like a wrap sheet yeah it's like a rap
sheet exactly so um
so not until they check the sheet that
they finally spot that um
so then when they finally checked this
rowdy sheet they finally realized
that this was someone else's uh suv
registered to that
uh criminal record and so
now he's being charged for like i guess
everything
everything just fell apart on him just
for the fact that he stole the car from
himself
from his other identity basically this
says
doctor what was it doctors
or something yeah not officer
yeah if officer if he had officer teja's
brain on
he wouldn't have gone to the cops and
said hey can you scrub my records right
now
he had the doctor's uh mind on but
anyways they put the police uncovered
the web allies going back over a decade
false degrees certificates and several
aliases
and uh pretty much his entire life and
career was a fabrication
and now he is gone
i wish i wish i knew someone that i can
talk to you too
that can explain to me what would compel
them to lie
so much about their background like what
what is it about that like do you hate
your life that much
to lying to be something else i could
see why someone would do it like
if if they really want the destination
but they don't want the journey to get
there so i think they're working yeah
they don't want to put the word so it's
easier to just be like i'm a doctor
i've been to a doctor like a hospital a
couple of times and probably
90 percent is treating the common cold
it's got to learn the lingo
uh penicillin the maxilla the
temperature yeah yeah yeah just like
just
and that passes off and also now there's
prestige yeah call me doctor you know
and then like they they get to live this
life
without having to spend the 12 years in
school i don't know dude it's too
stressful for me because i'm like man
okay i'm pretending to be a doctor right
now what
if that then what what do doctors do oh
[ __ ] they have to like perform surgeries
on kids and i'm like
i don't know if i could do something
like that it's hurt it's it's it's
hard yeah it's like it's sad out of
everyone here i feel like you would be
able to pull it off then
because like your your troll videos and
whatnot you pretty much
put on the put on the persona you play a
role and then you hold it together
act like you got to know what you're
doing right like a porn director
or uh you know i have a
varied history of fraud no no question
you're probably lying right now you're
probably not even a comedian you're just
something else oh i'm definitely not
coming you're not even steve
he's a fitness guru that's right
[Laughter]
i feel like i feel like tiff would not
even be able to do
nurse even though she worked in the
hospital as a medical tech
but then like even as a close thing it's
like
sorry sorry i'm a medical tech like no
it's gonna look like a difference i know
i can't i just can't [ __ ] do it even
if i like depended on it i think i would
[ __ ] it up
what if it was to save i was gonna say
casey
he just could see the answer coming a
mile away so yeah isaac
oh then it was definitely no because
it's usually
your kid no matter [ __ ] yeah what the
love of a mother is just way crazier
for the kids so that's what i feel like
sure okay there's but isaac i
just included them both in a bundle oh
family oh that building
yeah they're both tied up back to back
like this they're tied up get back
isaac casey let me stack it with your
kitties too
that's a lot of ropes now can you do it
oh i will try my best but i think i'll
still [ __ ] it up nice
how many more people do we gotta tie
into that she's trying though for other
people
she'll lie for other people which is
honorable that's fun
true true when you laugh at yourself
you're a piece of [ __ ]
you're lying just to like make the world
know that i don't know like you're like
a doctor or something important
right oh that's a piece of [ __ ] like why
yeah but if you're lying
to protect your family that makes a lot
that's honorable
true true but yeah so they give you guys
some answers on this guy's background
he uh grew up relatively poor
uh dropped out of school ran away from
home
only to end up meeting a guy by the name
of ys
peru shatan ready and i looked that guy
up and apparently he's a
a pretty big deal somebody in india like
another lie expert
i i don't know there was he recently
passed away so
like so and the media covered his death
so i was like oh this guy must be a
pretty big someone was he lying about
meeting him or he actually met him
true maybe he did you know but as the
story goes
um this guy helped uh helped uh
teja secure uh like an entry-level job
and
pretty soon he found himself uh in the
midst of this medical world
and he realized how how beneficial it
was to be a doctor
and so he ended up somehow getting
himself into
a a program uh for an internship
so he started interning at a hospital
and that's where he learned
the trade of being a doctor and he
learned just enough
just enough to get by and start
impersonating a doctor for the next
couple of years 16 different hospitals
pretty not bad not bad actual ages
though
because you said 23 but you could be
older right upon uh
upon arresting him they realized that he
may not be as young as his uh
yeah but you know what he could
definitely play a doctor on youtube
that's true i'd believe him yeah
i would do anything tell me anything
about corona i believe you yeah he looks
like a doctor
can you imagine this yeah this guy was
helping corona uh chronovirus patients
i mean he was doing it for ten years
right like he probably actually learned
some [ __ ]
you know what would be great she should
have just went to med school for her he
actually healed a [ __ ] ton of people
why he's all good and it's like wait a
minute he's our best doctor
yeah so sham anyone could be a doctor
oh yeah is that where you're going so is
it is it is it really harmful if you lie
that you're a doctor
probably not yeah it is because now that
any dumbass could come in
we just got or they got lucky if he was
really smart he's giving hope to the
millions of people that want to be
doctors and he's like oh
you can fool these people for many many
years and never have to go to school
let's let's let's [ __ ] give them some
props dude
that's tight 100 percent problem yeah
100 good job
props given
[Music]
you